مجلس النواب محسوم
للجمهوريين بحسب استطلاعات الراي اما
الصراع الحقيقي فهو في مجلس الشيوخ
وتحديدا في الولايات الخمس التاليه اذا ده
جورجيا وسيكون
وريزونا في نيفادات توجد اربع مناطق
انتخابيه للجمهوريين افضليه الفوز في
المنطقه الثانيه اما المنطقه الانتخابيه
الرابعه فستذهب
للديمقراطيين الذين يمتلكون ايضا افضليه
طفيفه للفوز
بالمنطقه الاولى ومع بقاء المنطقه الثالثه
غير محسومه لاين من الطرفين جورجيا
تتضمنوا 14 دائره انتخابيه ضمن الجمهوريين
تسعه مناطق منها مع بها اربع مناطق
للديمقراطيين بينما لم تحسم المنطقه لم
تحسن المنطقه رقم اثنين قرارها حتى اللحظه
وفي
مناطق انت غبيه في شعبه الجمه واخرى مرشحه
للانضمام اليهم بينما يظهر اللون
الديمقراطي الازرق في منطقتين هما الرابعه
والثانيه وكنت سلبينها يمتلك الحزب
الجمهوريه افضليه كاسحه سبع مناطق
انتخابيه وافضاليه طفيفه في منطقتين اما
الديمقراطيه فهو مرشح للفوز باربع مناطق
ذهبيه ومفضل للفوز في منطقتين الاضافتين
مع طبقي الصراع مفتوحا على كل من المنطقه
الثامنه السابعه عشره تسعه مناطق انتخابيه
اريزونا مناطق انتخابيه التاسعه اللون
الاحمر الجمهوري على ست مناطق منها ثلاثه
شبه محسومه وثلاث مناطق اخرى تميل
للجمهوريين بينما اكتفت الديمقراطيون
حسنين منطقتين فقط نعم خلاكهما الافضليه
في المنطقه الثالثه